Olha essa descoberta que acabou de sair
e que pode mudar completamente como você
pensa sobre exercício. Você sabia que
apenas 7.000 passos por dia já reduzem
em 11% o risco de desenvolver câncer?
Pois é, um estudo britânico com mais de
85.000 pessoas mostrou que não precisa
se matar na academia ou correr maratona.
O que realmente importa é o volume total
de movimento, não é intensidade. 7.000
passos equivalem a 5 ou 6 km ao longo do
dia, incluindo aquela caminhada até o
mercado, subir escada, andar pela casa,
andar na empresa. Veja bem, quando você
se move regularmente, está combatendo a
inflamação crônica, melhorando a sua
imunidade, regulando hormônios e,
principalmente, controlando o peso. A
obesidade hoje é um dos maiores fatores
de risco para câncer. Então, essa
caminhada diária está literalmente
protegendo as suas células. Então, ó,
pega o celular, vê quantos passos você
deu hoje e tenta chegar nesses 7.000.
Pequenas mudanças, grandes resultados.